joining me now is Louisiana Senator John
Kennedy uh Senator as I said at the
outset of the angle this seems almost
vindictive at this point what's your
read
more I'm trying to uh to be more careful
now that I know uh
you can be slapped for telling a bad
joke but
um in my opinion unless you have
untreated mental illness most
fair-minded Americans understand that
while Republicans are not perfect
the other side or at least most members
of the other side are crazy
and the leader of course to the of the
other side is President Biden President
Biden has been an almost perfect example
of ineptitude
the bite Administration stands for more
government higher taxes more spending
more debt more regulation a weaker
military abortion on demand they want to
turn cops into social workers
the Biden Administration has mismanaged
Congress it's mismanaged covid it's
mismanaged uh immigration it's
mismanaged crime it's mismanaged
Afghanistan and it's mismanaged
inflation
but it's worth asking why I mean there's
some smart people in the Bible
Administration and I think the answer to
that is clear too the bad Administration
has embraced and is being run by the
wokers
um it's it's easy to recognize the
walkers
they they hate George Washington Thomas
Jefferson Dr Zeus and Mr Potato Head
the Walkers also hate America and they
want to beat the crap out of it
and uh the workers think they're smarter
and more virtuous than the rest of us
they think all non-wokers or racist and
ignorant and misogynistic uh they think
they we should shut up and listen to
them and let them run our lives and and
they'll let us maybe eat meat
occasionally and that is a long-winded
way of explaining why the majority of
the American people right now trust the
Biden Administration like they trust a
Kmart bathroom
that's an insult to the Kmart bathrooms
out there Senator but I'll leave that be
speaking of the inflation problem
earlier today the president suggested
once again that it's not really his
fault
Putin's invasion of Ukraine
has driven up gas prices improved prices
all over the world we saw that in
yesterday's inflation data
what people don't know is it's 70
percent
of the increase in inflation was the
consequence of Putin's price site
because of the impact on oil prices 70
percent
uh we're not sure where you got that 70
Line the inflation rate was at 7.9 in
February versus 8.5 now Senator they're
trying to spin this like it's a
messaging problem this is a policy
problem through and through but they
keep doing what obviously isn't working
given these disastrous polls for them
well here's what the American people see
first the president blamed inflation on
uh covet and then he blamed it on greedy
business women and greedy businessmen
and then the president said inflation is
caused by unemployment and now he's
saying Putin did it uh and as as I've
said before I wouldn't be surprised if
the White House tried to claim tomorrow
that inflation originated in a bat but
the truth is that President Biden has no
one else to plausibly blame but himself
and all the American people know
let me put it another way when a honey
bun costs 20 bucks
and you're homeless on the beach eating
seaweed most Americans are going to
blame President Biden as they should hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else